everybody here go around the round table
what is the prediction because now
they're in the washington post new york
times saying joe biden's got to go
kamala harris pete buddha judge what
happens to joe well have you heard the
things that like they're trying to
figure out whether like is it jill biden
was asking whether did you read those
things jill biden was asking whether or
not they can get rid of kamala yeah i
don't oh really oh yeah i don't know if
that's true i just read no no that was
even that was i was watching it it was
like on msnbc when before i came on this
if you said
at the end of the day like they've got
to find someone who could fill joe
biden's shoes but if they decided to
have pete buttage edge leapfrog over
kamala harris it's going to be wild
because even like the hardcore lefties
are going to abandon each other well
like
it's going to get really wild because
the people that wanted her in there
because of identity politics and now
have a point of argument even whether or
not they think she was good or not they
think that she got in they wanted her in
for whatever specific reasons and now
she's in and you're gonna have this guy
leap frog over her if that happens if
they think the only way they can win in
2024 is pete but a judge we're gonna
have wild and see i am kissing jose he's
really politically smart knew this 20
years ago but he's doing it now
exactly they're clearly pre-positioning
buddha judge to take over it's all over
the freaking no no no no
it's a trial balloon because her
approval ratings are 28
right uh everyone in washington hates
her gavin newsom hates circus she took
the california uh position for the
presidency away from him wow so he hates
her of course he hates her because she's
because you hear me talking [ __ ] i'm not
that way they cut your nose
[ __ ] that's fake it's a false
flag
careful alex you don't want to get in
trouble with that
[Laughter]
i still they're gonna i think they're
gonna take michelle obama or oprah 2024
i think they're possible no way okay
well they're openly saying everywhere
we've got to replace biden now that's
everywhere so i'm asking what are they
planning that satchel page thing was
over the top people like check
check please what was that this is the
negro thing it was also the negro
leagues and said
he goes there's no he's the number one i
won't even say it he's the best in the
world yeah did you see though when the
when the judge in the i i keep going
back to right now's case the judge said
i hope the asian food is not on the long
beach port yeah they were like what a
racist
joe biden comes out and said you know
took the heat off him let's be 100
clean here right on this whole thing the
point is he's degenerating
clearly something's wrong so you can't
very much it's not it's not fair it's
not it's like to judge him like in
comparison to like judging obama when he
was in office or judging you and trump
when he was on it's not fair he's got a
problem there's something wrong with him
right it's not as simple as i don't like
the things he stands for or the special
interest groups that have got him into
power i don't like his politics that's
not what's going on here this is like
this is a man who's compromised
something's wrong and he's deteriorating
and either we admit that and we all
admit we all know it or we don't admit
it so we don't admit it then china just
starts [ __ ] filling up facebook with
a bunch of fake pages and we we have
chaos constantly you know i mean that's
that's part of what's going on like with
the the conversations that people are
having on nobody respects us because of
him right and it is it's insane he's the
first president who's literally shitty
poopy pants michael mouse ladies
give it up for michael mouse i think
that's what's part of what's happening
you know it's like we're we're in the
cult and if you're in the cult you have
to pretend that the cult leader's okay
you know the cult leader's not okay in
fact have you seen all the pointers
they're opening their mouths more and
more people going hey we gotta do
something and be like okay okay okay and
so they're coming out of this [ __ ]
fog and they're going what about that
people the ditch guy that well he's
spending three months off for his
[ __ ] kid like that's okay people have
short memories let's get them back in
here what about the meme i see you today
of like the hollywood guys going he's a
rock star he's punk rock i mean they're
still some are still trying oh that's
joe biden yeah yeah well pete
does have intelligence agency
connections so he he was tried to be as
the kind of prop guy they did try to
push him so i wouldn't be surprised if
they try to push him against the
mainstream media let's admit this the
majority
corporate media put in biden the
corporate media will be putting in the
next president of the united states
is the fall guy they're definitely going
to try but the problem is they don't
have like a clear like a person that
stands i go oh like on the right if
trump wasn't around you'll get ron
desantis to go that's the guy yeah he's
strong
he's reasonable
he's strong he's reasonable he's calm
he's made great judgment choices during
this pandemic with florida they've
turned out to be like
although controversial ultimately you go
good to like the end result good choices
well you know why i don't want to like
business in terms of like real estate
all these different things that didn't
deteriorate like they did in these other
countries where they kept the same
mortality rate you look at florida's
business florida's business did very
well in comparison to like california
but california took a big hit the
restaurants and even though they have
the same sort of mortality rate when you
adjust for age florida did better and
then when you look at business florida
did way better california has doubled
the cases of florida right now
but but here's the next question but
whose fault is that
i didn't get like money because i
supported trump i didn't think trump was
perfect i thought that he was you got
pokemon dollars right exactly i thought
it was more of a populist better than
you know what we were being offered uh
and so with hillary clinton who i know
is evil but but now i almost see trump
as destructive because he becomes the
opposition to the democrats but he's got
his own issues i want to be populist not
left or not right but americans coming
together and saying no to joe biden know
the democratic party a lot about
russiagate and all of it i don't think
trump's a bad guy but i want to be clear
at the end of the day he went along with
warp speed he went along with the
experimental shot and he's pig-headed
and he won't admit he was wrong so i'm
not going to criticize biden and pfizer
for this and fauci and then give trump a
pass and with trump's base i go to these
big events
with five 10 20 000 people they're
really upset and then trump is so
pig-headed that he is still going along
with the vaccine
we have to say always talk to your
doctor about what's right for you don't
take advice from people on the internet
talk to your doctor if you're feeling
unwell and you want to get advice on
what you should do to treat yourself
take yourself take care of yourself take
your booster shot vouchers
now they're doing uh this show is
outrageous new york has announced
booster shops i'm not comfortable here
the uk now it's now [ __ ] trailer on
the side of the road
welcome
i was like i was like joe come on where
are you we're in a trailer on the side
of the road england is announcing
if you don't have the boosters you're
going to be locked in your house just
like austria and australia and france is
too friendly but let's not talk about it
because they'll ban us on there you're
right i want hundreds of shots and i
think i find i think trump's wonderful
then alex jones is saying
i'm sick of [ __ ] trump right now i'm
sick of all these [ __ ] people why
haven't you guys gotten him drunk yet
we can't do that that's bad you haven't
even thought but listen listen
there's a big difference between
someone's private medical decisions the
way i see it is i i went to the doctor
you went to the doctor and they gave us
specific medical advice joe let me tell
you when when i when i talked to the
doctor i actually asked them i said i
don't want ivanka or zpec i said the
monoclonal antibodies fixed me up just
right good and the doctor said
no i want you to finish what you've been
prescribed and i said do i do i really
have to and they said yes because if it
comes back this is what we're
prescribing you and so i was actually
like kind of critical and the well the
media still lies about it the point is
if you go to your doctor and you figure
out whatever you want i don't care
that's fine do what you want to do if
you if you know a lot of people have
asked me like would you get the vaccine
now well i got regeneron the monoclonal
so i can't and it provides eight months
of protection or whatever that's what
they they're saying the point is
mandating by government a medical
procedure for you to buy lunch is
[ __ ] insane it is we're already
swearing on the show
it's over but but if someone if look i
i've got we've had so many people on the
show who are like uh one one guy was in
his 50s and he says doctor recommended
he got it he's absolutely fine he feels
great
if you choose to do it i don't care what
you choose to do i'm not going to
pretend to be a doctor i'm not going to
pretend to know the secret to the
universe but i will stand up and say
[ __ ] the government if they're going to
tell you hey you have to you're
obligated to get a permanent medical
procedure otherwise you can't work you
can't eat food you can't go to the movie
jim jim let's fact check this
faucey and gates came out last week in
videos i've played like 50 times people
can pull this up and they both said oh
sorry it really doesn't work or do
anything we've got a new vaccine coming
out after six months there's basically
no immunity from the shot that's not a
vaccine that's that's a change
yeah on come on come on like the
challenge with this stuff is no no no no
joe tell them i'm not i mean i could
yeah it wanes it wayne's after time well
the real problem is it's unscientific
because they don't recognize the natural
immunity from previous infection like if
you have a real infection with kovid and
you recover you have a more robust
natural immunity it's been shown by the
israeli study which is 2.5 million
people that have between 6 and 13 times
better immunity than you got from the
vaccine
they're in denial about this so they
negate this and they pretend that it's
difficult to to measure but it's not
difficult at all we do it at my studio
all the time you do a very simple
test for antibodies you can see it very
clearly if it's a you know
it's you do this this test you get a
drop of blood and you see your immunity
you find out that you have antibodies
it's not hard if that's the case that's
just as good not just as good let's be
kind and say it's as good but let me get
this
better it's far better than you get if
you got infected
hold on he got covered he recovered so
he has six to 13 times better immunity
than someone who gets the vaccine has
like two weeks recovery from the vaccine
and now can go out into the world he's
better better
i'll say two things the first is that i
think politically this uh
is a pitch rat
because a pit trap a trick if you you
walk and then you stumble through the
leaves and you fall into the spikes
because right now they're saying we are
going to mandate three shots in the uk
austria france and then what happens is
you end up with rand paul who i like the
guy but he says why aren't we taking
natural immunity into the into the case
and i said why are you in any way
excusing mandates for medical procedures
whether it be a test or a shot if if
we're talking about natural immunity
we're talking about you going to a
facility taking time out of your day to
get a medical test done if you want to
buy food no no no he's he's taking one
step he's taking one step in this
examination of this narrative in their
direction
no no no he's saying
one step in the navigation of this
narrative is to look at what you're
ignoring yeah why aren't you allowed to
talk about natural you're ignoring
natural immunity well i know your your
whole case is [ __ ] so everything you
say whether you're in for mandates
whether you're telling children they
have to get it whatever the [ __ ] you're
saying as soon as you say your natural
immunity from previous infection doesn't
count or you try to pretend that it's
impossible to check when you can check
in seconds if you vaccinate someone
they're not good for two weeks you can
check their immunity in seconds i have a
[ __ ] video of my phone of me doing it
let me just say this the fda put a
letter out last week under a four-year
lawsuit
and they said no one that we've looked
at over millions who had natural
immunity has ever transmitted the virus
but everyone that takes the vaccine can
at the same level i don't buy that i
think people just haven't reported
whether or not they transmitted the
virus and that's not it's simple it's
like you have to like somehow another
they have to like
quantify that you had the virus and then
gave it to somebody else
yeah someone who gets uh this is this is
exactly what they say if you get the
vaccine you're i think it's an order of
magnitude less likely to get sick and
it's less severe if you do get sick
you're equally likely to transfer the
virus someone else but
just came out and said that's not true
anymore i have the freaking clip right
right after a while you're still gonna
get sick i've had
three friends now be hospitalized that
were vaccinated well so so we had
hospitalized with kovid thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time